welcome to this video playing stock
sinners stock sinners from Iceland guess
it's Iceland I'm getting better with my
flags I need some I think I really do
okay the Queens gambit exchange it's
very classical way to to play and this
is some one of the best lines with
knowledge five it's not down so popular
but it's really a good way to play
this is my idea I'd like to get some
play on the queenside going this is
interesting here lets me take on 1b6
okay um yeah I don't know if this really
is good maybe maybe this is a paper
black but I have my doubts a form yeah
come on break it up break it open rather
jump now just piling up here looks III
on Brooks III probably
yeah I'm just trying to get all the
pieces I'm near the king and for once
I've been rather quickly I've been quick
and not quickly i played quickly all
right Oh what is he doing I don't
understand this really I I can't take c6
song why not black resigns hey yeah this
is a strange strange one he bled
everything instantly and then he gave
way c6 and resigned yeah it's an ID to
do this bed of course here he can play I
don't know something like this and then
we continue it's probably a position
where white is somewhat better the
computer gives me almost a winning edge
here which I don't really understand and
the line doesn't really look too too
frightening for black I mean it is nice
for white no doubt but why does not
winning here computers so somehow too
optimistic if a computer can be
optimistic yeah very very quick game
what I can tries to explain a bit more
what it's normal here Knight b6 is a bit
strange I mean that's a wrongly put it
is strange to let it take you can
normally blinked X Y and then one idea
is to play like this no g7 and Bishop f5
this is a very popular and um noteworthy
maneuver that you should remember it's
just a very good plan to get rid of your
bad bishop and that can be applied in
various structures where this night is
fianchetto would so to say and then it
prepares this exchange maneuver
something to yet to remember
okay thanks for watching this very brief
game